should we be surprised that within hours
of learning about the monkey pox
outbreak that is being investigated uh
The Usual Suspects are already
promulgating and promoting conspiracy
theories no
we should not be surprised when all you
have is a hammer the hammer of we're
going to tell you who's really doing
this like the global-ish globalist
internationalist trotskyite Socialist
unlike Obama trudeoma Crown yeah exactly
it should not surprise us that Marjorie
Taylor green and Alex Jones and others
are already ramping up with the
conspiracy theories Marjorie Taylor
green is focusing in on Bill Gates Bill
Gates uh and his uh remember early in
covid the idea was well Bill Gates
through what looks like just
philanthropy
is
um trying to donate to vaccine
development to surreptitiously track
people's location through vaccine
microchips or whatever okay here is
Marjorie Taylor green on Bill Gates and
smallpox Gates why is Bill Gates running
everything why does he get to decide
that you know Bill Gates I want to
remind everyone he wants to grow fake
meat in a Petri dish and he wants a
peach tree what it says to drink poop
water so I don't know why we're letting
Bill Gates decide our health decisions
but I didn't think we were here's the
deal uh Bill Gates is very concerned
about monkey pox because this is
something apparently he can make a lot
of money off of and him and his other
buddies but in the blue blue blue blue
state of Massachusetts someone has
contracted monkey pox perhaps they got
it from Canada from Justin Trudeau's
lovely country up there it doesn't
appear that the fact that there's a
Canadian Nexus has anything to do with
Justin Trudeau's politics it it seems to
have to do with Canadian travelers to
other countries but yeah do we even care
about the facts when you've got a great
story and then even now they're
reporting monkey pox cases in Sweden and
Italy that is disgusting and it is
terrifying nasty horrible big
bubbles of pus on your skin I mean
clearly nobody wants this so they're
gonna have pictures of all of these kind
of terrifying images they're going to
show children with this all over their
faces and of course they're going to be
from I don't know where they're going to
be from and then they're going to tell
you you have they're going to be from
vile countries wear a mask from because
if you get close to anyone's face and
they spit on you you're going to
contract this horrible terrifying
disease monkey pox but don't worry you
got to go ahead I know you have a Dr
fauci pillow that you sleep with every
night we need to order your Bill Gates
pillow you gotta have she should have a
body pillow of Bill Gates and you can
cuddle with it every night because Bill
Gates is going to save the day very very
sick woman now of course if it's sexual
contact that is the mechanism for spread
for monkey pox primarily right now it's
not really clear that some kind of full
masking protocol is really what we need
now it is true that masks can help
prevent the spread of monkey epochs if
there are respiratory elements but
monkey pox doesn't tend to spread via
what we would call small respiratory
droplets or aerosolized respiratory
droplets like covid now with all of this
they stuff she mentions Bill Gates but
who is always the they she mentioned
Massachusetts so maybe she thinks
liberals in Massachusetts are going to
be putting this stuff but it's it's the
the vague they obviously Bill Gates
isn't the one doing any of this stuff
and then we go to Alex Jones Alex Jones
insanely claims that it could be the
coveted vaccines that are causing monkey
pox and watch how he puts this together
monkey pox pops up in more than 20
countries right all over Europe all over
the U.S all over everywhere where you
have people taking AstraZeneca
AstraZeneca and J and J ladies and
gentlemen
because what is AstraZeneca and J and J
right they're virus vectors that inject
the Genome of a chimpanzee
into your cells and then orders
yourselves to replicate under those
orders okay so the argument from Alex
Jones here is
the jnj vaccine inserts a Simeon Simeon
means of monkey uh provenance a simian
genome and listen the word monkey is in
Monkey pox after all so therefore you
know published internationalist
trotskyite socialist yeah
um humans are mostly getting monkey pox
from other humans so uh this is a
completely harebrained and completely
free of evidence conspiracy theory but
remember when the explanation for
everything is somebody who's lied to you
somebody who's done something to you a
government
globalish which are disproportionately
Jewish men when in all of these
global-ish conspiracy theories it's
Jewish men
um when you have those scapegoats of
course you're going to go to them so we
will be following the monkey pox
outbreak from a science perspective from
a perspective of empiricism and things
that we actually know and can say with
certitude
um if you're just listening today and
you're morbidly curious about the clips
I played of Marjory Taylor green and
Alex Jones you can find them on our
Instagram page at davidpackman show
as I've said many times before I believe
that the secret to personal finance and
it's not really a secret isn't about
timing the market or picking individual
stocks it's basically asset allocation
and in order to determine asset
allocation you've got to know all of the
different assets that are out there
that's why I joined a community called
alts and we asked them to be a sponsor
alts is a newsletter that makes the
world of alternative assets accessible
to anyone even if you're new to it alt
does the research on alternative assets
that no one else is doing right now and
they break it down for readers in a way
that's nuanced then it's easy to digest
and honest and provides you with just a
ton of valuable insight into what assets
are there and this could be baseball
cards Collectibles music rights comic
books video games the alt newsletter
demystifies
these investment markets for you their
recommendations have a track record that
you can check out on their website and
you can also learn about the alts One
Fund which contains a blend of
alternative assets including
Collectibles and art and music rights
and the things that I've mentioned you
can find that and the free newsletter at
davidpackman.com
alts the link is down below